existieren eigentlich aliens oder sind
wir allein im weltall zehn punkte warum
es aliens gibt welche meint ihr sind
wirklich stichhaltig und welchen ein ja
ein bisschen an den haaren herbeigezogen
mein name ist christoph krachten und das
ist kitsch um science und fiction
es gibt gute gründe warum aliens
wirklich existieren
die zehn populärsten argumente für
aliens gibt es hier in diesem video
manche davon sind stichhaltig andere
kompletter bullshit was meint ihr
schreibt in die kommentare
erstens kornkreisen vor vielen hundert
jahren wurden sie zum ersten mal
entdeckt geometrische figuren in einer
solchen exaktheit dass sie nicht
natürlichen ursprungs sein können und
nur in seltenen fällen haben sich
menschen als deren schöpfer geoutet was
sind sie also sind es botschaften von
aliens die uns warnen wollen
oder senden sie uns damit
friedensbotschaften es ist ein großes
rätsel
zweitens die aliens uhr jeden tag suchen
weltweit tausende computer mit der
software seht rom die frequenzen die
aufgefangen werden nach signalen von
aliens ab jeder kann mitmachen jeder
kann das auf seinem computer
installieren und so steigt die
rechenleistung von jahr zu jahr
wissenschaftler gehen davon aus dass
über kurz oder lang in diesen signalen
einnehmen signal entdeckt wird in 30 bis
40 jahren müsste es der fall sein
zitat ansonsten stimmt etwas nicht
repinski fonds seit menschengedenken
werden sogenannte unidentifizierte
fliegende objekte auf englisch an
identität klein object sogenannte ufos
beobachtet die aliens sollen uns schon
seit ewigen zeiten observieren und es
gibt sogar berichte davon dass sie
menschen entführt und untersucht haben
barry abpfiff die man auf das streng
geheime testgelände sollen 1947 die
überreste eines abgestürzten ufos
gebracht worden sein
es soll in der nähe von roswell in new
mexico abgestürzt sein und sogar
zeitungen haben damals darüber berichtet
seitdem würden dort die überreste des
ufos und die überlebenden aliens
untersucht und sogar technologien die
dort erforscht worden sein sollen würden
heute für anwendungen geräte und
besonders fluggeräte verwendet werden
soll sich zu einem zentrum für alien
kontakte entwickelt haben und es soll
sogar konferenzen mit
extraterrestrischen lebensformen dort
geben fünftens die entstehung von leben
aus der ursuppe sind die bedingungen auf
einen planeten optimal entsteht quasi
gezwungenermaßen leben auf diesem
gestürmt das heißt es müssen bestimmte
grundbausteine des lebens vorhanden sein
wie zum beispiel wasser und wenn dann
noch die richtige menge zum beispiel an
uv strahlung oder blitzen durch gewitter
als wenn energie vorhanden ist bilden
sich immer komplexere strukturen aus
diesen chemischen grundsubstanzen und
schließlich werden aus diesem komplexen
molekülen die ersten lebensformen die
chemiker stanley miller und herren haben
das in den 50er jahren des letzten
jahrhunderts durch ein experiment
bewiesen dass das funktionieren muss sie
haben diese ursuppe nach gemixt haben
dann energie in form von blitzen rein
gejagt und tatsächlich sind die ersten
organischen verbindungen dort entstanden
wie zum beispiel aminosäuren die
vorstufen zum leben und das spricht
dafür dass die theorie stimmt das heißt
wenn die richtigen bedingungen auf einem
planeten vorhanden sind das dann über
die jahrmillionen gezwungenermaßen aus
den grundsubstanzen leben entsteht
wasser auf dem mars es ist eine
sensation die raumsonde curiosity hat
wasser auf dem mars entdeckt beim
baggern ist sie ausgestoßen und wenn man
jetzt das klima auf dem mars mit dem auf
der erde vergleich dann stellt man fest
dass in höhlen auf der erde zum teil
sehr ähnliche bedingungen wie auf dem
mars herrschen und in diesen höhen auf
der erde
da gibt es bakterien das heißt es könnte
tatsächlich leben auf dem mars geben das
heißt aliens in form von bakterien
siebtens alien fossilien aus dem weltall
der astrobiologe dr richard fuller will
fossilien in meteoriten entdeckt haben
die nicht von dieser erde sind das heißt
fossilien von aliens sie entsprechen zum
teil blaualgen die sie auf der erde gibt
aber zum teil sind es auch lebensformen
die hier total unbekannt sind also für
ihn der beweis dass das alien von zielen
sind achten
die nasca linien gegen sie sind die
kornkreise ein klacks auf 500
quadratkilometern in peru finden sich
riesige abbildung von tieren linien und
es gibt sogar ein abbild eines menschen
der der astronaut genannt wird
für diese bilder gibt es viele theorien
und sie sind ein großes rätsel
was hat es mit dieser nasca kultur auf
sich wurde sie von außerirdischen
geschaffen hatten die mitglieder dieser
nasca kultur kontakt zu außerirdischen
sind es botschaften an die
außerirdischen sind die langen linien
landebahnen für außerirdischen es ist
ein ungeklärtes rätsel bis heute 9
exoplaneten jahrhundertelang tappten die
astronomen im dunkeln es war nicht
möglich
außerhalb unseres sonnensystems planeten
zu entdecken
vieles sprach dafür aber es konnte nicht
nachgewiesen werden täglich sterne
wurden millionenfach entdeckt waren also
planeten eine besonderheit unseres
sonnensystems waren wir eine ausnahme im
ganzen universum für das leben sind
planeten unverzichtbar nur auf ihnen
können bedingungen herrschen die das
entstehen von lebensfähigen komplexen
strukturen ermöglicht erst vor 20 jahren
wurden die ersten planeten entdeckt
allerdings war leben auf ihn nicht
möglich inzwischen sind es mehr als 1000
exoplaneten entdeckt worden sind und um
den stern gliese 20 lichtjahre entfernt
im sternbild der waage kreisen
wahrscheinlich zwei planeten mit
erdähnlichen bedingungen außerirdisches
leben wäre dort also möglich
die größe des universums die drake
gleichung der us astrophysiker frank
drake ist das problem einfach mal
mathematisch angegangen er geht davon
aus dass für die bildung einer
zivilisation lediglich bestimmte
bedingungen erforderlich sind
zum beispiel muss das zentralgestirn des
systems also wie bei unseres
sonnensystems das darf nicht zu hell zu
dunkel zu schwer oder zu leicht sein
der planet auf dem das leben entstehen
kann muss in einem bestimmten abstand um
dieses zentralgestirn herum kreisen
seine rotationsachse wird am besten von
einem mond stabilisiert also wie bei uns
und noch ein paar bedingungen müssen
erfüllt sein
und diese bedingungen die packt man
einfach in diese drake gleichung und die
wahrscheinlichkeit der existenz solcher
planeten kann dann ganz einfach aus
gerechnet werden
allerdings variieren die ergebnisse noch
ein klitzekleines bisschen die
schätzungen gehen von einer zivilisation
bei uns in der galaxie der milchstraße
aus bis zu vier millionen zivilisation
also da gibt es eine gewisse bandbreite
ja was meint ihr wie viel die
zivilisation gibt es wohl in unserer
milchstraße
und was meint ihr was stimmt welche der
zehn punkte sprechen wirklich dafür dass
es aliens gibt schreibt cindy
kommentare wenn er mehr darüber erfahren
wollt ob wir in einer matrix leben
dann schaut das letzte video und wenn er
mehr über schwarze löcher erfahren wollt
dann empfehle ich euch dieses video
ansonsten ich würde mal sagen bis dann
bleibt dran